Did "Shazam: Fury of the Gods" catch lightning
in a bottle again or is it just another overblown,
overstuffed sequel?
Twitter's surprising reactions are pouring
in.
As James Gunn and Peter Safran prepare to
kick off the revamped DC Universe — leaving
the DC Extended Universe largely behind — we're
witnessing the final few releases that were
greenlit prior to their hiring.
Before we get to check out fellow holdouts
like "The Flash" and "Aquaman and the Lost
Kingdom," we'll get to meet up with the Shazamily
once again for "Shazam!
Fury of the Gods."
This sequel to the 2019 film sees Shazam and
his superpowered family take on godly new
foes who threaten the entire world.
Ahead of the release of "Fury of the Gods,"
some critics were fortunate enough to see
the sequel early, going on to post their reviews
online so potential moviegoers know what to
expect from it.
Overall, most are in agreement that it's,
well, just fine.
It has its big moments and gives you what
you would want from a Shazam adventure, but
ultimately fails to surpass its predecessor.
Of course, these assessments come from a small
group of critics.
What does the wider DC and Shazam fanbase
think about this long-awaited continuation?
Thankfully, for those curious, reactions to
"Shazam!
Fury of the Gods" from the general public
have begun to pop up on Twitter..
Based on the earliest reactions, it has become
even more clear than it already was that fans
and critics don't always see eye-to-eye.
Many folks on the social media platform have
been quick to voice their support for the sequel.
One user wrote:
"Shazam Fury of the Gods is a lot of fun.
Idk if it was better than the first movie,
but the villains and the action were definitely
a step up."
They also enjoyed the film's handful of surprises
and two post-credits scenes.
Another user rated the sequel a 10 out of
10 and highlighted the comedy as one of its
strongest elements.
That seemed to be a common theme, with other
Twitter users chiming in with their appreciation
for the movie's comedic side.
A lot of people seem to be fans of the new
characters and worldbuilding elements as well.
"Okay, I feel like maybe I should be writing
all this down."
Fans are certainly admitting that "Fury of
the Gods" has its flaws, but they don't outweigh
the positives.
As one user said:
"It's these amazing characters sprinkled with
a heavy dose of heart that makes it all worthwhile.
SHAZAM FURY OF THE GODS is endearing, hilarious,
entertaining and epic.
Helen Mirren stands out as a great addition
to Shazam's roster."
They also note that it's a crowd-pleaser that
goes bigger than the first "Shazam!"
movie and packs in some big twists.
At the same time, just because some DC fans
aren't in sync with the critical consensus
doesn't mean all of them are.
People have also taken to Twitter to express
their disappointment in "Shazam!
Fury of the Gods" for one reason or another.
One user voiced their exhaustion with comic
book movies of this style, posting,
"What made Shazam unique was portraying a
kid endowed with powers.
That is almost completely abandoned here for
yet another 2hrs of good capes punching bad capes."
Other users weren't impressed either, specifically
calling out the film's VFX shots as unforgettably rough.
Meanwhile, one fan had multiple complaints
about the sequel, ranging from the pacing
to what they considered to be a total misuse
of Helen Mirren and Lucy Liu.
"We end this now."
"Yeah, we do."
At the end of the day, reading Twitter reactions
to a movie is no way to form an opinion on it.
If you wanna really figure out where you stand
on "Shazam!
Fury of the Gods," the best way to do so is
to check it out yourself.